previously on raft working well wait
really okay so we need to go
north-northeast
we need to go seven two zero one boy or
about 400 meter feets away god it's so
far when we get there better be amazing
I see something
Oh to what internet what is that
ultimate rap yeah that's something too
legit it's uh real tall I'm taller than
ours which I didn't think was possible
and now I feel like slowly incompetent
yeah I feel like I really let you down
on the construction side of things
I thought ours was gonna be like some
Commission first to call you babe
used to check the head of time on that
that's a hard no my mistake I made a bow
yeah what I made a bow just in case
there's people on that boat and I gotta
kill him who them a wind turbine look at
that [ __ ] what oh my god
we gotta kill him we we gotta kill like
all of them I'm kind of with mark on
this one Oh like half-submerged
yeah idiots submerged and they're both
won a bunch idiots
they're good to the ground Oh Oh sir do
I deploy the anchor deploy anchor I like
not captain wait there's words here
Robby boats gone bastard shark is after
me gonna stay here until I find a way
off this place well I don't know what
that could mean
laying around that seems good yeah
trapped under there I got caught shark
named him Bruce Bruce you bastard I got
you
Bruce ooh wah Oh chopper yeah he's he's
near around he's around guys there's so
much scrap here it was weird a briefcase
I got a briefcase oh that is weird said
new note added where is a note add teeth
oh you have a journal oh my god
we have a journal two months we've been
working on these reactors two months
working to save the world with no one to
tell our story Oh blah blah prototype
not stable Chinese team no one knows
what happened to it Ren is supposed to
be one of them but he's not letting
anything show
I'll mumbled something emergency cooling
system looks shoddy oh did someone melt
the ice caps that's not good yeah you
don't want to see that note I have
another note all right what you got okay
so January I wish I knew where we were
that we had someplace we could point to
except that radio tower out in the
distance
twelve sixteen and eight failed today
after three days of testing 16 score
burned so hard and fast it ate right
through the wet well its payload sank
into the ocean hot enough to burn for a
hundred years
Sparrow check the radiation levels
what's being led out with every test
they said they're confused those in
shelters we can fix this she said and
the craziest part is we agreed us four
overworked exhausted pet ok the new note
just I was reading that oh yeah I don't
know why I turned the page in my turtle
us poor overworked exhausted pencil max
we would save the world what would be
left of it anyway
February question mark turns out Ren
blew the whistle on us and it made the
people in charge mad they must have
known we were stalling working on 12 and
24 those things let out so much
radiation they burned green for God's
sake except they look like them anyway
sure
owl and I put up a fight but they just
shoved us around that bunch of jocks
that's so [ __ ] hard to read what's
wrong with this font chuck Sparrow and
reactor 8 with them too after all Ren
knew she was the only one with the
smarts to keep them working they left us
behind on the reactor testing platform
then blew the foundations the water's
been rising slowly owl thinks we should
go after them I wish I didn't agree with
them what the hell what I picked up note
5 which just looks like a little bit of
a quick log trace 8 the January distress
call received trace 9th of January
established report language unknown Mele
get taragan 2nd of February comm dead
gunshots in distance Tangaroa 4th of
February someone speaking Mele too fast
to make out Koda jengar Koda Shankar 6th
of March tarragon found dry place
leaving water rising and we're short a
couple places I am sorry
8 March Mike if you reading this head
for
if it's still above water there are
supplies in the pantry Wow
parkour away I got there's two notes up
here some place called a utopia people
number two eight six six oh it's high
seas so that if we go to heading to
eight six six I'm betting we can find
some people oh if you can understand
what you're reading this isn't the end
wait is this what you read I don't read
that one okay we've done the engine this
hard and fast we could but I think
burned-out we barely made it to the
radio tower al said the boats useless I
can fix it they're probably way ahead of
us but I think they're headed for Saline
I just want to leave this someplace
anyone can find it we didn't cause this
but no you just read this didn't you and
then maybe I'll ask her out and she
won't look at me like I'm crazy this
time I'll found my notepad but I got
back I need to hide it better next time
this marker makes it really hard to
erase stuff but we'll get her back we
have to read though okay mark are you
all the way up top yes I am that's all I
could find up here their fault damage in
this game uh yeah
how about into the water no sweetie I
shouldn't be sploosh Oh shark please
don't know Bruce more up there though I
didn't see you can check you assume I
can parkour up there which has been a
big with one little stabby
oh it's dead oh sweet I need to eat
something and then I'll get down there I
forgot that you guys were live I could
have said some horrible things that's
Wade Wade Oh seriously oh god that hurt
not the bite didn't even bite me but it
hurt me it's scary
mark two eight six six it's in the
journal I think that's I got into 866
shall we make our way out of here yes
800 okay that's not too bad er that's
much worse which direction
Oh northeast front compared to what was
first with commander what
they're kind of facing our could just go
northeast got to have alright I think if
we're judging from the way the radar is
pointing as North I'm gonna guess system
look at this guy inventing systems a
missing in just unlike someone can we
get confirmation that more than one sale
actually makes you go faster because I
feel like we've got three and I feel
like we should be just blasting ass out
of here but it it does still matter if
you are with the wind correctly or not
forever I'll get a streamer up then get
my streamer back see where the winds at
again one of those dope streamers there
bro dude Wow okay work we're kind of
with the wind we're kind of with the
wind
yeah bow yeah what of it oh good look
man every time man every time I got a
thing and you're just like wow mouth
yeah yeah yeah ever come out of our
mouths
making more glass because I'm assuming
Bob you want another water purifier
that'd be cool we could have an upstairs
and downstairs water purification might
be nice if you decide to be nice to be
so mark how do you make one of them
water pure for vacationers I gotta make
glass I got glass cooking right now oh
it's yeah oh there baby good good bliss
actually you know what I've got plenty
of sandal me why not here take or X I'll
make it for you I got it don't worry you
sit there you sit down I'll make it for
you oh god I'm gonna hide of you sir
thank you sir that's right oh just sayin
that's that's really tight thank you I
have always wanted to be tight alright I
got here I'm gonna put it up in your
food because I'm gonna go steal some
food do it I want you to do it alright
water purifier in your food taking some
of these roast beets there we go now we
got high directional nets my good dudes
Wow look at these layers upon layers of
nets we have absolutely just slurping up
the bounty of the ocean
this shirt Wow no no you don't how do i
fire this arrow oh god Aaron I should
have learned how to fire you I never
fired it before take it easy
I told you to put my dick put me on the
back burner I told you and you not the
back burner still on high dude no dude
listen listen look I'm listening
Shh look look I'm gonna put I just made
you two more water purifiers you've got
three new look I'm assuming if you maybe
you water the trees more I'm looking out
for you man
I could water the trees Morrie I'm
looking out play drums they're in your
food container sir I get to select where
they go yes sir sir sir sir know where
we can start crafting ourselves armor
and a backpack for expanded inventory
what is that a thing that we're supposed
to know if you look at the research
table it shows you those stuff that we
haven't researched how do we research it
then mr. scientist yeah we're starting
to find animals I mean I've gotta know I
know I'm pointed to Thanks thank you all
the water purifiers are online thank you
for your hard work
kind sir your water purifiers will not
only supply us with life-giving
delicious Bertha juice they will also
supplies with delightful a water cooler
discussions Oh teamwork really does make
the dream work
do you want another one I can make you a
no one I really don't need another one
all right I made you another one I
that's it's in your food just welcome oh
yeah the raft
oh Jesus gonna make gonna make the
thank you you you you blank blank blank
all right now paddle away fast
all right paddle away fast okay if I
paddle away wait all the way that way
Bob point the point point that sails in
the other direction why are we doing
this got to get away from him this is
our chance just you and me okay
you would be welcome back Wade I never
doubted you thank you anyone got any
like seaweed was anyone picking up
seaweed I know anyone had any weed no
why not now what's going on
what dude I live in California a that's
right you guys have kale chips and Kim
Beach and we don't know why you say like
that
that's where you have to is legally
mandated and say for Nia was like thou
shalt say weed brother mark Bob come
take a look at this we have three pings
on the radar one no 48 I don't know what
the uh-oh
with the battery died yeah
just two more nets I mean so 500 meters
behind us there was something we're
passing that on someone say oh you need
two more
what do you mean one more someone say
net I can't clear you there's one hole
still though
you need I will make another for the o12
I've done it
Oh sir dude we're gonna be collecting so
much juice stuff in every direction
forever this is the greatest this shark
isn't coming I smell Emmys coming in
fire fire - give me my arrow back oh I
only got one wait mark come it is what's
up what do you have on your face
mmm what do you have in your face well
you have like a rebreather on your face
what is that my oxygen bottle how'd you
do that I built it with my hands how do
you put one of those on I can't tell you
all the secrets some you must find for
thine self good luck to thee never
crafted a thing in your life I'm sorry
are you hungry
would you like some of my infinite
supply of food you know your food is
garbage all right we're back to fighting
friendship with Bob ended I'm friends
with Wade now I have a friend yeah you
and me we're friends now Oh what do I do
about nothing doing for nothing how do I
clear is there an ointment what do I do
what's going on look at this hangout
space that I just created for you
ungrateful pieces of garbage all right a
little rude he's right whoa
friendship with Wade ended me and Bob
her friends now how do you like that
light I can't deny this is really tight
is it a shark in comments
shark didn't coming I see him he's going
for it no not today not today
cheered down by the sails and I believe
that's where the one who isn't friends
with us sits Oh are you doing I'm
putting undoing the chair what why did
you do this well I have my own chair
well now we have four chairs one too
many chairs yes we have four of for
sales I can show on the ocean who's
right now yes we us us is bought is it
that thing too slight to the north
directly north
I know we have four I could just fix
that right I'm ready to kill
once this bones nasty yes yes when I see
it yeah it's our battle yeah yeah I see
it start paddling mm-hmm don't make that
don't take that tone with me
I was drinking soda pop uh what tone
would you like a nice one
yes sir I see it on the horizon there
straight ahead
what tone would you like them a nice one
how many times I have to say it
hey I do see it I see it on the horizon
you're great this is great not not
talking to you
it's not a yacht we're almost past the
point of where I know how to do anything
okay well you didn't know how to do
anything anyway so it's not really
saying a lot ah my paddle broke wait how
do we get on set yeah some food with you
this is a bit of an exploration no
there's got to be food on it it's a
yacht silly yes and I don't have any
food I'm going into this with like no
food so I'm really hoping this food yeah
it's gotta have food on it yeah I found
the entrance found this honker of a tree
I cannot that's deeply saddening I've
got vine goo recipe they gave me a
recipe there's got to be food on here
all right perfect is great there's good
stuff mark how'd you get on ah as for me
to know and you never know I was like on
your side don't just now well it's very
fickle this whole dynamic is just like
up in the air at all times
I don't mind being like the villain cuz
like you you're gonna like the
friendship with Mark last like 10
seconds but the memories lasts a
lifetime
I got a mechanical part hey I got a
mechanical part guys let me know if you
see any food I'm really starting to get
hungry I'm like inches away from my
Barbie hunger being you want you can eat
some of my nuts dude really I'm gonna
drop you one nut at a time mark one of
those was a nail I'm really sorry where
I hear scoop your nuts off the ground
yeah I'll not Elfman huh yeah these are
good nuts dude you're nuts I've always
said your nuts are the best doesn't seem
like you're actually able to jump up
this probably not theirs oh no I did I
got up here you just got a yeah you got
a wiggle oh my god what are you Jesus
Christmas Helda a my head lamps yeah you
know you're right hang on Oh God it
disappeared now I can't show you guys
there was a [ __ ] there's horrible rap
monsters is it really just a crouch-jump
I can't do it I got a key card to help
what does for something
oh god it's another one of those things
Oh batteries remind me to do it update
why now my computer I keep saying remind
me tomorrow it's like now oh it's been
like an hour oh let's do this well Stan
let's do this dance and it's I'm just
gonna give up on that completely poof
man it's dark I'm not gonna give up at
all there's a lot of good resources
under the water here another mechanical
point of scrap metals requires one car
jack
what do you mean requires one car jack
you do not know what game this is mark
we have car jacks take a breath no no
requires wood bomb I need a car jack
gonna need the green key and I need a
bomb it's like you're doing crimes mark
Suzie I think so
I've been roped in did you get sucked it
dude it's a slippery slope there's like
they put cocaine on the table and then
they stack $100 bills and I just I don't
know
there's my mind this is oh there's
another one wowowow a lot of ow ow a lot
of ow I didn't get any key I said I
needed it
you got a key card no oh I did get a key
card I thought I heard someone told me I
should sail away with the raft what okay
I thought I got a key card I do not have
a key card unless it went into the tea
which if it didn't craft because you
have your big boat now I figured I could
just oh no oh no oh no I'm gonna die I
might die or I'm running away I'm
running away this is not worth it I'm
running away I'm running away this is
horrible I'm running away I'm running
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm
running away this boat is cursed we
should just wait until day time this is
a curse why have we done this I just
flopped this headlamp I crafted you
crafted a headlamp out you're crafty
idling a battery all right fine keep
your secrets what happens if you need
the raft got wet wait no wait wait um
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait here
yes wait buddy wait Bobby Oh Bobby's um
Bob oh oh oh did you need something I
see you down there mark ah me throw
something to you sorry some food or
something no oh
that's four digit code wait do you uh
know what's happening right now
he doesn't seem super concerned about
all right it's gonna not worry about it
wait Bob is taking the raft unni's
running away from with it I'm gonna
control what I can control and I'm gonna
sue oh hey let's cook food I just found
in here oh wow that's great yeah that's
good oh wait is he coming back oh hey
Bob
[Laughter]
thank you standing up there like that
yeah okay somebody yeah that's a big
raft yeah looking at it from a distance
we made a lot of progress on that raft
we our raft you know the one that we've
all made together hi yeah it's good how
is how is the handling it really does it
goes quick yes especially when it's
going away right your board right Marc I
mean I'm getting some food why what's up
I'm just making sure all right
oh I see I'm good
interesting excellent excellent actually
are you guys banding what I wouldn't
call it that
hey Green Key I needed one of those yeah
it snagged it unlocking some [ __ ] great
that is great oh you guys don't go into
the bottom entrance anymore okay unlock
down there good good I'm worried about
that four digit code that's nice that's
good I could really use some water you
guys aren't a [ __ ] me right now right
well it'd look gross yeah we would not
do that we would not do that this oh I
got the bird did you murder the bird I
frigging headshotted this bird
electrical wires that's some good stuff
you're finding but do these notes are
killer yeah thank you so much for
writing that down in the journal we all
share oh you know what mark I just
realized you what's up oh it's not on
the raft oh I thought we were forgetting
something he was running a bit smooth I
need it do you want do you want to hang
out do you want to be on our raft should
we come get you
I would like to have some water from
yonder raft yeah I mean like what are
you I am dehydrating as we speak on lack
of water
you'd hate to hear that so you swimming
to us would take a while is what you're
saying yes I would die very you would
die are you sure hundred percent
Wade you don't need to being silly
you're surrounded by water I don't know
what your problem is all right so did
you solve the mystery of the boat
already do we have to I was working on
it but you [ __ ] life
and um us leaving was nothing to do with
you not knowing how to prepare for an
export yeah yeah you need some personal
responsibility here or else you're never
gonna go anywhere in life oh you know
this is kind of creepy in here Oh God
oh my god these stupid rat bastard they
get steak
they don't give steak I take a steak
they're made of steak they are made of
stick yes that's true
always Bob with the wise words there's a
shark attack I feel like the shark isn't
even a problem anymore
I mean he does still eat things got a
lighter mark this mark guy look guys
stop ripping on me we were just ribbing
on weight and now your ribbon on me
please you're a reason to rip on wait he
got all the [ __ ] done while you [ __ ]
were over there stuffing your oh my god
family friendly while you guys were over
there
TRUCKING your own tricks and you know if
you had a coaxial or you could just beep
yourself yeah I ate a raw chicken
probably good all right um I found a
lighter and a we got a lighter and a
bullet is that enough to make a bomb
because the bomb goes up on the bridge
door you go wires how do we connect
these we got lighter wires bullet
mechanical parts it's got to be
something about a fob see if we can
craft the bomb I think it's on the first
floor where did the way what we're put
it together
Oh interesting
well where's this room mr. Minow this
boat working my way downtown is it like
the carjack room is that what it is you
need a card maybe
well that light is handy yeah like
cheating to me if I'm honest Lukie from
the bloop here this is the blue key
someone say there's another entrance to
the ship that we're missing
mm doesn't seem right all right I'm
gonna go I'm gonna jump into the ass of
the boat there better be a door why
would there be a door at the door Oh at
the ass of the boat that's fine Bob see
chat like helpful like Bob I got a
reporter in a crowbar apparently oh
that's
no good find Bob that's a new note good
fine Bob good fine good fine great find
actually poor jack oh that's the thing
we need
hey bolt cutter we're just finding
everything mark taking some time jerking
it you know that's not my favorite thing
that either I'm on the boat and alone
yanking my dong oh I can use one bomb
should I use one bomb or do you guys
want to see the bomb being used hang on
yeah I'll wait I'm not gonna just blast
open my headlamp is officially burnt out
it's okay I'm pretty sure the bomb is
gonna provide some light when we do this
how close do you think I can be to this
bomb when it goes there you go three two
one should I be away from
[Music]